Donald Trump's convicted personal
attorney Michael Cohen has been
testifying for hours maybe by the time
you watch this maybe by the time you
listen to this it will be over I have
not missed a minute of it up until I
came into the studio to start working on
today's program Michael Cohen came in
armed with documents and exhibits to
support his claims about the criminality
of President Donald Trump off the top we
were told that there would be a sort of
limited scope to avoid questions related
to collusion with Russia which didn't
seem like it would allow for too much
discussion about that but fortunately
because Michael Cohen included some of
those elements in his opening testimony
anyway there actually have been a fair
number of questions related to Russia it
doesn't look good and we're going to get
to that but if you watched the beginning
of it 15 minutes were devoted solely to
Republican objections that there should
even be testimony Republicans tried to
use procedural rules and technicalities
to prevent the testimony from even
happening I mean desperate to prevent
Michael Cohen from testifying that went
on 10 or 15 minutes before the event
even got going and then Michael Cohen
launched into his opening statement
which was filled absolutely filled with
extraordinary bombshells the truth of
which we'll talk about in a moment right
whether people believe Michael Cohen is
a separate question but some of what
Michael Cohen talked about in that
opening statement includes he regrets
working for Donald Trump and having done
what he did okay I think anybody would
say that in his position he openly calls
Trump a racist a con man and a cheat and
then backs it up and importantly right
off the bat Michael Cohen confirms that
individual number one in documents
related to Cohen's indictments is indeed
Donald Trump he says that Donald Trump
knew Roger stone was talking to Julian
Assange of WikiLeaks and knew in advance
of when DNC email drops which had been
illegally hacked we're going to be
released this directly contradicts known
statements from multiple people an
absolute bombshell that Donald Trump
knew of
this ahead of time this was denied time
and time and time again Michael Cohen
told the story of being in Donald
Trump's office when Roger stone called
on speakerphone and told Trump I just
got off the phone with Julian Assange in
a few days there's going to be this
massive email dump of Hillary Clinton's
emails and Trump responded that it would
be great
according to Michael Cohen which means
that indeed Michael Cohen is testifying
that Donald Trump was involved in the
release of the emails which he made a
big deal about during the campaign as a
campaign issue against Hillary Clinton
Michael Cohen talks about having a check
which he brought as evidence
written by Donald Trump from Trump's
personal account after Trump became
president to reimburse Cohen for the
hush money payments that's a bombshell
Cohen has multiple copies of these
checks cut to him by Trump while Trump
is president to repay him for the
illegal hush money payments for which
Cohen is going to prison that's a really
important point Cohen is convicted and
is going to prison for the hush money
payments which Donald Trump paid him
back for during the presidency of Donald
Trump Cohen describes talking to Trump
going to the Oval Office and Trump
saying hey those next two payments are
on their way they're being sent in from
New York and it takes a while for them
to work their way through the White
House mail system Cohen presented
financial statements of Donald Trump's
given to banks like Deutsche Bank which
is a bank at the center of this
investigation talks about misuse of
donated funds handwritten notes showing
that Donald Trump arranged and this is
so narcissistic as it is disgusting and
corrupt and a misuse of donated money
Trump arranged for a straw buyer to go
to an auction and buy a portrait of
Trump to go up in one of trumps golf
clubs as we've previously reported which
Donald Trump later reimbursed with
donated funds meant to be charitable
contributions and then Cohen also gets
into what we now know is the truth
Trump Tower Moscow which is that
negotiations were taking place about
Trump Tower Moscow during the campaign
and what this means is that you
simultaneously had Russia trying to help
Donald Trump defeat Hillary Clinton and
at that same time you had Donald Trump
negotiating to build from tower Moscow
there were plans a builder had been
lined up there was the idea of giving
Vladimir Putin a 50 million dollar
penthouse as a sort of sweetener to make
the building more appealing to other
oligarchs and Cohen interestingly in the
midst of all this explained how Trump
tells him to lie he says Trump doesn't
show up and say go and lie Trump shows
up and looks at him and says there's no
business in Russia Michael there's no
business in Russia and it's a sort of
wink wink for Michael Cohen to go out
there and to say what Trump knows is a
lie and what Cohen knows is a lie and
what everybody knows is a lie which is
that there actually is business in
Russia this is how a mob boss operates
meanwhile according to Michael Cohen
Trump would ask him regularly how's it
going in Russia how's it going in Russia
because everybody knew that there was
business going on in Russia that's not a
question especially when you ask it six
times
that suggests Trump is unconcerned with
what's going on in Russia or the Trump
isn't aware or involved in any of it
racism Cohen says Trump told him black
people would never vote for him because
they were too stupid Cohen says Trump
regularly inflated his assets to be
listed as wealthier on the Forbes list
exactly as we suspect it and might
explain why Trump is desperate for his
tax returns not to become public Cohen
explained that Trump directed him to
threaten lawsuits against Trump schools
if they ever disclosed his grades or SAT
scores because they're terrible and when
it comes to Russia Cohen says he doesn't
have proof but he has suspicions and he
actually tells the story of a time
shortly before the Trump Tower meeting
took place when he was in Trump's office
and in comes Donald Trump jr. and walks
right behind Trump's desk something that
people would rarely
do and leans in close and says quietly
but loud enough for Michael Cohen to
hear that the meeting is all set and
Trump says okay good let me know Michael
Cohen now believes that that was indeed
when Donald Trump was being told that a
meeting with Russian actors meant to
provide dirt on Hillary Clinton had been
arranged had been confirmed and would be
taking place again direct contradiction
of what Donald Trump previously said we
were told by Trump and attorneys and all
sorts of people that hot Trump had no
idea whatsoever about it of course the
more we learn the more we realize that
nothing goes on nothing goes on around
Trump without Donald Trump's specific
involvement and Michael Cohen testified
to that as well today okay so what are
going to be the reactions to this
Republicans as I mentioned went in ready
with attack questions and just trying to
attack Michael Cohen's credibility as
someone who can't be believed Michael
Cohen is simply saying yes I I did lie
before and I'm going to prison for it
and I take responsibility he's there
voluntarily it would be extraordinarily
boneheaded I mean Paul Manafort did it
but it would be extraordinarily
boneheaded at this point to voluntarily
put yourself under oath and tell lies
that you know are going to be
scrutinized and could lead to even more
significant jail time prison time etc so
on the one hand playing it
conservatively
if only 5% of what Michael Cohen says
and has said today is true it is a
blockbuster of absolutely historic
proportions that being said I don't
think he's going in there and lying and
again there's not really anything he's
embellishing on you can believe that he
straight-up making everything up whole
cloth right but he's asked questions he
answers them in verifiable ways you can
go and check whether what he says is or
isn't part of the record as he claims it
to be and if we're going to use past
lies as a barometer for determining
whether whether some determined
whether someone can be believed in the
future Donald Trump has told according
to different trackers anywhere between
eight and twelve thousand lies as
president of the United States if we
can't believe Michael Cohen ever again
because he said some things that weren't
true to investigators then we can never
believe another word of anything that
Donald Trump says and it's funny I
mentioned that to my audience a lot of
people in my audience already don't
believe anything that Donald Trump says
so the next steps will be testimony will
finish more Democrats and Republicans
will get the opportunity to ask Michael
Cohen questions then we will see the
spin cycle on the news tonight I may do
a YouTube livestream talking about some
of the reaction Democrats likely will
say this points to specific criminality
by Donald Trump that needs to be further
investigated and dug into in specific
detail new investigations are necessary
we need to call more witnesses to
testify before the House Oversight
Committee Republicans are going to say
we can't believe this guy this is a bad
guy this is a convicted felon and
there's nothing to see here and
ultimately it's going to come down to
Cohen's credibility and what impact this
has on other investigations that are
taking place but to me Michael Cohen
is a guy who at this point has no reason
to lie and has a lot to lose if he's
willing to show up be sworn in and under
oath say things that are demonstrably
untrue and I think we will find out over
time that today he told the truth
whether consequences will come out of it
whether there will be any willingness by
the Republicans to say you know what
we've got to put party aside and we have
to take this seriously because it is
serious this is the crisis not what's
going on at the us-mexico border then
maybe we will actually see consequences
or the potential of consequences
otherwise I would not be holding my
breath let me know on Twitter what you
make of the testimony whether you think
it will have any actual material impact
on the future of Donald Trump's
presidency I'm skeptical but I'm willing
to have my mind changed
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show